To remove the quotation marks
around names in the first column,
we can use replace function
within the formula tool
to replace the quotation marks with no
character, thereby getting rid of them.
We attach the formula tool, choose the
name field to update on the functions
tab, choose the name field to update.
Open up the string functions, and
look for the replace function.
We're going to double-click on it to
drop it into the expression area.
The string is highlighted, and so
we're going to select the field
that we want to update.
We go to variables, existing fields, and
select name, double-click on it
to drop it into the expression.
From here we're going to identify
the string we're looking for,
which is a quotation mark.
So we put that where it says target,
and we put single quotes around it.
If this was any other character we
could put it in double quotes or
single quotes.
Where it says replacement, we simply
put an open quote, close quote,
to identify that we want to replace
it with nothing, thereby removing it.
When we run Ultrix,
we can now see that the quotation
marks are removed from the name field.
Next we'll need to get rid of the extra
letter at the end of the zip code.
We can remove the extra letter
by simply taking the first five
characters of the zip code,
starting from the left side.
This will result in us
dropping the last character
when there are more than five
characters in the zip code.
To do this we choose the zip code field
as the output field in the functions.
To do this we go back to
the formula tool, and
choose the zip code field
as the output field.
In the expression box,
we go to functions, string, and
we choose the left function.
Double-click to drop it in,
and where it says,
string, we replace with
the zip code field.
Where it says, LEN, which stands for
length, we type in five.
When we run the workflow, now we'll see
the zip code with just five characters.
Lastly, we're going to
remove the currency symbol,
in front of the numbers,
in the amount field.
This is somewhat similar
to the first field,
where we were getting rid
of the quotation marks.
But in this case,
we have multiple characters to remove.
We go back to the formula tool,
select the amount field,
and instead of using
the replace function,
we use the function called,
replace CHAR.
Double-click to drop it down, the string
is replaced with the amount field,
and the y is replaced with a list of
characters you want to replace inside of
the quotation marks.
To do this, we simply just list out
the characters, no need for a comma or
delimiter in between them, but
we make sure to put them
inside of quotation marks.
Then, we replace the z with the value
we want to replace it with.
We want them to replace with nothing.
So that is represented by an open quote,
close quote,
basically nothing between the quotes.
We see that the currency
symbols are now removed.
So this is three ways to remove extra
characters dirtying up your data.